a free code camp welcome to another the
daily programmer web series and in this
video we're going to be talking about
the problem three one four concatenated
integers posted on the daily program or
subreddit so let's go ahead it down the
whiteboard okay so this concatenated
Andrews problem is defined like so find
a way to concatenate the numbers inside
of this array in such a way that you're
given the min and the max concatenation
and what we mean by that we can just go
ahead and write out all the different
permutations of which we can concatenate
these numbers together and then find the
number which is the greatest and find
the number which is release greatest so
in this case we're left with six
permutations where we start with the one
we can start with the 9mm sort to ten
followed by the one and the nine of the
ten and one etc and it turns out I do
were to loop through all of these
numbers and try to find the max our max
number would actually become this number
and our min would actually just be the
opposite of that
so if you notice nine one 10 is our max
and the opposite is actually just to
reverse so 10 1 9 which is 10 1 9 down
here so we've kind of made an
interesting observation about this
problem is that the max is just a
reverse of the min so since that is the
case it would make sense that if there's
a way to sort this array from min to max
so I'll just go like this if we find
that array and sort in such a way we can
just simply print out the man in the max
by either traversing from left to right
or right to left so in that case how
would we actually sort this array and
does sorting the array actually work so
let's try to convince yourself that
there is a way to sort this array in
such a way that gives us our min to max
so it turns out if you wanted to have
this array set up in such a way from n
to max it would make sense that you need
to start with the lowest number and that
when that numbers can count any with
another number it gives us the lowest
possible number versus contending with
another number if that makes sense so
again let's just go ahead and work this
out let's say we have an a here this is
a and this is B those
make more sense to have this b19 or does
it make more sense to have a d9 one so
if a plus B is less than B plus a we
know that we found a good order and we
need to keep it there so just to say
keep a as is otherwise if we have a plus
B is greater than B plus a we need to
swap the elements and if they're equal
so if equal keep the same and so what we
mean by this if we were to check is 1/9
less than 91 it is so we can just go
ahead and keep these numbers as is and
then move on to the next check in this
case we actually have else here and then
we have else here but it doesn't really
matter because these won't equate the
true unless the other one is false
so in this case we know that one in one
should come before the 9 let's move on
and move the B over here so we're going
to check the same thing is a plus B
which is 110 less than B plus a which is
101 and it is not less than it's
actually this one right here so we need
to swap these elements because again it
makes sense that we need it to become
the minimal when concatenated together
so 110 kind of should be swaps to be 10
1 so that should make sense again if you
just follow this algorithm here we can
just swap them or keep them the same
as we iterate through our array and then
now that we've reached the inner day
array here with the B we can increment a
and do the same check is 9 plus 1 or
concatenate together less than 1 a 9
it's not it's
this case we're going to hit which is 91
is greater than 19 so again we need to
swap these numbers because it makes more
sense to have the one concatenated with
the nine versus the nine cat name with
the one so we switch this to a one
switch this to a nine and at this point
we have finished sorting the array so we
can get rid of these little annotations
that I added and again if we were just
to print out left to right so men so ten
one and nine we got our men so if we
were to print this out right two men are
from right to left we are going to get
our maximum which is going to be nine
one tenth all right so one more time the
recap is the problem can be solved by
sorting the array and the hard part is
figuring out the function to sort the
array by and it turns out our function
what we need to do is just take catenate
a would be and then check if it's less
than concatenate would be with a so
let's go ahead and implement this in
JavaScript all right so in JavaScript
let's first declare a function and I'll
call it get min Max which takes an input
as a parameter which is just going to be
that array of numbers and then here
we're going to go ahead and just call it
so get nan Max and it was going to go
ahead and pass those numbers in and just
to make it simple let's just convert
these all to strings I know the example
has as integers in the subreddit but
let's make it string so it's Egypt for
us and then we can just go ahead and see
get the results and then we just print
out the results here and just to verify
that will just say results that man is
equal to this string and then results
that max should be equal to this string
right here so now that we have a kind of
a basic setup where we pass in an input
and then we expect
Amanda max for our min Max function I
was going to go ahead and return an
object to the properties
in and the property's max and we can
just go ahead and just set those in null
for now and then we can kind of work
through one by one of how to get this
working so the first thing for getting
the men we first need to take the input
strings and then we need to sort them
and let's go ahead and pass in some
anonymous callback function so takes a
and B as a parameter and what we need to
do here is actually really really
straightforward and really easy to do
instead of having that long drawn out if
statement we could just return a plus B
so akin technique would be minus B you
can cut in with a so this will give us a
negative number if the a should come to
the left of the B and just give us a
positive number if the a should come to
the right of the beef so again if
negative we should keep it the same if
positive we need to swap them that's
kind of what's going on behind the
scenes but we're using JavaScript sort
and not the manual sort that I'd end the
whiteboard so that we've taken the input
and we sort of them at this point we can
just call a reduce function which again
is going to take an anonymous call back
function so a string value and then what
we can do is just return the string and
keep concatenated with the value so I
can do something like that
that oh yeah Simon : and then that
should give us the min that we're
looking for and if you saw at the moment
I put this comment here we go down here
line 20 it's printing out true and that
is because results if I were to print
this out our min is actually equal to
what we expected
so therefore this function is working as
expected
and it's the exact same algorithm that
we worked on the whiteboard we have the
input array and then we sort it based on
that whole logic that we worked up and
then we can connect them all together
using a reduced function and then that's
printed out and verify against this
expected output down here so the max we
need to do is just reverse the array so
if they reverse here and then we can do
another reduced function to just print
it out so now down here we can see on
line 24 results it is printing out the
expected results for max and min these
are both true so that way there we
pretty much implemented the entire
algorithm that we did in the white board
using JavaScript sort method reverse
method and reduce method and just a kind
of bat take a step back because I did
like the condensed simplified version
this is very concise instead what we
could say is if a our pars end of a plus
B is less than pars int a B plus a we
could return a negative number and then
otherwise we return a positive number
and then after the same return zero this
is the exact same logic basically as
this line 12 was the only differences
we're kind of actually writing out how
it works and then down here we see that
we're still getting true and the value
still matched so obviously there's
factoring is still working but this is
kind of to explain you know the whole
algorithm that we did in the white board
this is how you write it with the if
statements but a more concise condensed
version would just be return a plus B
concatenated minus B plus a concatenated
and that would give us the same result
alright so that wraps up the
concatenated integers problem again if
you have a different solution feel free
to post it in the comments and it also
liked this tutorial if you thought it
was good and be sure to subscribe to
free code camp below alright thanks for
watching
you